spärlich beleuchteten led lampen die
wohnung der frischverheirateten ein
stromausfall im ganzen wohnblock doch es
könnte viel schlimmer sein
die beiden sind am leben und unverletzt
auch wenn die erinnerungen an ihre
hochzeit vermutlich für alle zeit zum
schlimmsten moment ihres lebens gehören
der laute knall der explosion war
schrecklich und direkt nach dem knall
fing die gebäude ringsum an zu schwanken
und sich zu bewegen
das war wie eine welle eine
erdbebenwelle die alles zerstört
first solar gmbh
erst schaute ich natürlich auch meine
frau okay war
sie wuchs außerhalb des libanon auf fern
von gewalt und krieg und solchen
nachrichten
sie hatte große angst und ihr kleid in
fetzen hielt sie einfach fest sagte
keine panik das war bloß eine explosion
nicht weinen sei stark minuten später
fanden wir unser auto und fuhren weg an
die nächsten zehn bis zwanzig minuten
und dann kann ich mich kaum erinnern
das ist alles weg am nächsten tag hatte
ich schmerzen am ganzen körper
ich weiß nicht ob das schock oder wegen
dem stress es war kein gutes gefühl
ich bete zu gott dass so etwas nie
wieder passiert aber ich bin natürlich
auch traurig und 2 wir haben jahre von
dieser hochzeit geträumt sie vorbereitet
mit einem schlag ist der traum zerstört
alles